politique ce soir au carré campagne nous
emmène à paris dans la sixième
circonscription où se présentent l'une
des filles de jean marie le pen marine
24 ans novice en politique mais fidèle
vous allez le voir aux idées de papa il
y a d'abord eu le challenge jean marie
une vie consacrée à la politique
puis marie caroline la grande huit
années de combat récompensé par un siège
au conseil régional
aujourd'hui marine la benjamine tout
aussi longue que ça sort tout aussi
imprégné de civisme familiale baptême
électoral
un brin précoce peut-être objectivement
24 ans c'est une vie assez courte mais
subjectivement nous avons été confrontés
en qualité de fille de jean marie le pen
à un grand nombre d'obstacles dans notre
vie et peut-être cela nous a forgé un
caractère plus combatifs et nous a donné
une expérience certaine du sens des
choses et de la valeur des choses
conseil de famille échange de recettes
le xviie arrondissement est une
circonscription difficile le fief de
bernard pot ce septième en intense à
penser que ces constructions facile
parce que
poussier est implanté depuis longtemps
mais je crois que les gens sont prêts à
ça prêt à changer
moi j'ai un meilleur accueil des
territoires du 85 jeunes accueille
beaucoup plus sympathique à neuilly
l'arrivée sur le terrain enfin plus
exactement à l'un des sièges du parti
marine a dû déserter la campagne une
semaine cloué sur un lit d'hôpital crise
d'appendicite aiguë la candidate est
convalescente pas de marché ni de
tournée des popotes avant quelques jours
il va falloir muscler pour compenser le
handicap
je pensais faire un truc comme ça avec
photo du candidat donc marine le pen
votre candidat trois dimensions cette
circonscription est avec derrière un
argumentaire je pensais m'être notamment
voter utile c'est voter pour vos idées
parce que j'ai un pion 17e se sont sont
assez influent ses paroles par
l'argument du vote utile élevées dans
l'air faire la stratégie 1re sur bernard
pons un candidat que l'opinion situe à
la droite du rpr monsieur pons bénéficie
d'une image qui est une fausse image et
que je cherche à ak c'est moi je cherche
à faire comprendre aux gens et aux
électeurs vis etienne qui croient voter
pour quelqu'un qui n'est pas celui qu'il
s'est dit être moi personnellement je ne
fais pas de de campagne au niveau des
hommes ou des femmes disent présente je
défends mes idées je crois que les
électrices et les électeurs du 17e au
connaissent bien
je suis député de cette circonscription
de 1981 connu élu dans un fauteuil il y
a cinq ans bernard pons avait obtenu 66
% des voix au premier tour après mars
fin de la parenthèse marine le pen
retourne aux affaires le cabinet de
l'avocat du front national
l'avenir électoral cela dépendra de papa
mais marine aura t-elle réellement envie
de se faire un prénom en politique